you're gonna have a lot of pandemic
friendships people gonna call you that
you never speak to and they're gonna and
you're gonna like my friends with this
person you might be but it's a pandemic
friendship there's gonna be pandemic
relationships you're gonna start [ __ ]
somebody that's near you because it's a
pandemic you know I tend to believe that
relationships aren't the most valuable
when they only make themselves known
during a period of absolute and utter
desperation and crisis you know what I
mean I tend to think in order to find
out who your real friends are free
associations needed the ability to leave
your home those small benefits of being
able to walk down the street and meet
other people and stand closer than six
feet away from them so just be a little
careful be a little careful with the
pandemic collaborations the disease
friendships you're making just we get it
don't be upset when they lift the travel
restrictions and that person travels the
[ __ ] out of your life that's all
don't don't don't be don't be afraid to
look at things with you know your head
right now as well as your heart